Hello, hello, Happy holo Year!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for joining us today for the 62nd episode.
And our first episode of 2024!
BAU BAU!
I definitely didn't say Happy Halloween.
I was like, Moco-chan, what did you just say?
I definitely did not say Happy Halloween.
Happy New Year.
You didn't hear anything.
No, you didn't hear anything, no.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's have a very, very happy start to our New Year, Ruffians.
Maybe, you know, your New Year's resolution is to wake up every day for FUWAMOCO Morning.
That would be pretty cool.
That would be cool, but just so there's no misunderstanding.
No misunderstandings!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us.
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
So, a way to start on the right paw is to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Why?
Well, it's a new year.
New year?
Do we have something new and exciting, Moco-chan?
New year, new pero sighting.
Pero sighting?
Do we have to start the new year this way?
I don't know.
Ruffians submitted it, so... I mean, we are asking for sightings of peros, so...
Is it a good Pero Sighting?
If you look at the left side and the right side of the picture, it's good.
Well, we love mitarashi dango, so it's good in that way.
I'll have the one on the left and Moco-chan, you can have the one on the right.
Ruffians, I think maybe it's for the best if you don't eat the one in the middle.
I don't want to think too hard about what my eyes are seeing and what my brain is feeling.
This is just a lot going on there.
Instead, I'm just going to look at how delicious the other dango looks right there.
How does it look?
Pero has his bones.
But, you know, I feel like this mitarashi dango here looks so delicious.
That maybe we might get a little bit carried away and poke ourselves there.
We gotta be careful, you know!
Ruffians, have you had mitarashi dango before?
It's not marshmallows.
No, not marshmallows.
Mitarashi dango is like a... Mitarashi sauce is like a sweet, but savory sweet sauce-based sauce.
It might take a little bit of time to get used to, but it's really yummy.
And then you have the dango, it's kind of like mochi, but not.
It's dango.
It's different.
It's very yummy, though.
Very yummy?
My favorite.
But you know, let's make sure to have lots of yummy food this New Year season, too!
I might have had a lot of yummy food during the holidays too.
Christmas.
But now it's New Year.
So... New Year food.
Another excuse for yummy food, huh?
BAU BAU!
Let's just forget about Peronia.
No nasties in the New Year.
No!
BAU BAU!
Now I'm extra hungry.
Well, speaking of the New Year...
Oh!
Wow, ruffians.
Like we said, it's now officially the new year everywhere!
New year everywhere, you know?
And so, it's the season to welcome the year with... Boys Pudge!
BAU BAU!
I think, you know, ruffians, you enjoyed our end of the year holiday theme, right?
Well, I think it was a bit heart-pumping for you, just like it was for us, right?
Yeah, well, now this is the perfect time to listen to the beginning of the year holiday voice chat too, you know?
Right?
You know, it's a fun time of year, lots to do together, you know?
Cooking, maybe some cleaning, or even just, you know, taking it
Easy together, maybe watching anime, playing games, those kind of things.
Maybe you'll have to listen to our beginning of the year voice packs to find out.
I can't wait for the English and Japanese versions!
It was a lot of fun.
We had a lot of fun, you know, so we hope that you enjoyed them just as much as we did.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, our friends!
Speaking of Japanese...
We had a bit of fun these past few days, Ruffians, you know.
Actually, as a part of some of the end-of-the-year festivities, we were invited to participate in the Yukuhoro Kuruhoro New Year's programming during the Toridaka Taisho!
Toridaka Taisho!
You know, we participated along with our senpai, and we watched a bunch of the best moments of the year for hololive!
You know, the clip that was crowned the Grand Prix.
It was something else, huh?
Something else.
A lot of chaos.
A lot of amazing clips, right!
NPC Nenechi.
Right.
Yeah, but you know, not just the Toredaka Taisho group, we also formed into AyaHobomi to the 3D Toon New Future!
I wasn't envious, no.
Right!
We all got to eat Osechi, a traditional Japanese New Year's food.
Yeah, a bit fancy.
Yeah, we had kamaboko fish cakes,
Black beans.
Kazunoko.
We're really happy.
It was definitely a fun start to the new year!
We're just really thankful to be able to participate on these programs and we hope that we'll get invited more in the future too!
BAU BAU!
Although, I still want to try.
Because I talked about trying ikura, and kazunoko, and umibudo.
All at once!
Sea grapes.
Let's call it that.
You know, you want ASMR, right, ruffians?
What about it?
That type of ASMR.
That's what Fubuki-senpai was suggesting, right?
Because they all sound very...
Popping.
Popping seafood.
Huh?
Yes!
I was expecting you to say no!
Seafood ASMR?
You're weird.
BAU BAU!
You know, we had a lot of New Year's fun, but with the New Year's also comes some new things, too.
And over at the hololive reddit, there's been some updates.
Some changes.
The changes, yeah.
You know, now, ruffians, you can select us and the other advent members as your OSHA icons!
You know, I don't really get it.
Apparently, it's a bit tricky to select both of us as your... A flair?
Not flair senpai, but a flair.
Oshi-aikon.
Is it different?
Let's go with that.
Okay.
But apparently, to be able to have both of us as your oshi-aikon, you have to select Yagoo-san first.
And then, you can select both of us.
I don't really get it, but there's some kind of ruffians that will definitely help you, okay?
I wonder why you have to ask Yago-san for permission first.
I don't know!
You'll have to ask him, okay?
But we hope that you'll pick us as your ushi on Reddit too!
I definitely, definitely never notice them.
Why?
Never, ever looking.
No, definitely not.
Then Biboo and Hana-senpai?
When's FUWAMOCO's turn?
Right?
But now, FUWAMOCO, we have BAU BAU stickers by me too!
I don't know if it's any different, but now maybe you can notice when it's actually us.
When we respond to your comment.
No, it's not a fake FUWAMOCO.
No, it's ice.
It's FUWAMOCO, Fuwawa, and Mococo.
No fake FUWAMOCO.
It's ice.
We hope to be able to have even more fun here on Reddit and, you know, enjoy hololive all together over there in 2024 too!
I don't get it too.
But, don't think, just jump.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, you know the new year, it's a time for maybe channeling luck?
Yeah, noon to noon.
And, well, Ruffians, I was wondering, do you have anything particularly lucky that brings you good luck throughout the day?
You know,
A special mug or a necklace or maybe a shirt.
Some sort of lucky item.
Those kind of things.
Not at all!
FUWAMOCO is your lucky charm!
You say that, it's gonna make us blush.
What are you doing?
It's the morning.
Wristwatch!
I guess ruffians don't really have lucky items.
We're the only...
Wow, I couldn't have given you other gifts, huh?
Well, though, actually, Fuwawa me, I have something like that!
I never said anything, but actually, a while ago, I came across a shirt that brought me a lot of luck.
A shirt!
Is it Mococo?
No!
I am not a shirt!
You're not a shirt?
I'm Mococo!
Well, the story is, you know, one day,
We were looking through some previously loved clothes in the Northwest Passage.
And randomly, I came across a shirt that had Gura-senpai on it!
Why?
Pretty lucky.
Ever since then, you know, whenever I kind of wanted extra good luck before, you know, like, auditions or something like that, you know,
Even debut, I wore it as a pajama shirt the night before, and then that way, I could get some extra love.
Ruffians, you know what?
I think it worked!
Kuro-senpai's luck!
You know, it's a very special lucky item of mine that has helped give me a little power during times where I really needed it, so I'm very thankful.
Would you like something like that too, ruffians?
Head pads!
If you don't wash it.
I wash it.
That sounded suspicious.
I do wash it, I do wash it.
That's normal, okay?
That sounded very suspicious though.
But you know, I really hope that maybe there's still some more luck attached to it.
If I wear it some more, maybe...
Gura-senpai morning!
After all, one of our goals this year is to get to know our senpai better too, right?
Now hopefully, now that we're out of the holiday time, maybe we'll have some more time.
Right!
Do some more collabs.
BAU BAU!
I hope ruffians, you can find your lucky items.
Well, we actually have some FUWAMOCO scoops from some ruffians.
Thank you for the very good channels, ruffians.
Our first group, yeah!
Our first group for today we have... Ruffians.
Did you hear about this?
Just the other day, Kiara-senpai and Ina-senpai did a special stream where they created their own interpretation of some casual clothing outfits for everyone.
It was so cute!
What do you think, ruffians?
You were there!
Did you enjoy the designs?
They were all so cute!
You know, it really, really showcased Kiara-senpai, Ina-senpai's personality.
Right!
It's wonderful too.
Yeah.
However though, when it came to Shiori's design, she kinda had something to say.
She wasn't too impressed with, you know, her tummy showing and kinda called Moco-chan, uh, shameless for showing hers.
Moco-chan, do you have anything to say?
Shiori.
Shiori!
You know me.
I'm not shameless!
You know, I... I just... tend to get a bit quiet sometimes, so... You know, keeping a tummy cool makes it a happy tummy, right?
Ruffians!
You agree, right?
That sounds like an excuse.
No!
I'm not shameless, okay?
That sounds like an excuse, yeah.
It's out of practicality.
It doesn't matter because... My tummy is cute, right?
So it's okay, right?
It's not seamless, okay?
It's practical.
No, I think it's seamless.
No!
My own system.
Moco-chan, what do you propose?
I think Shiori should apologize.
Shiori!
I'm waiting for your apology, Shiori!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the scoop, Ruffians.
Thank you for telling me about the horrible things Shiori said.
Ah, that's terrible.
That's rough.
Wow.
There's been some more scoops, too.
Hopefully better ones.
Hopefully better, yeah.
Wow, wow.
I think there was a senpai that had some extra, extra special luck recently.
Because... Wow.
Hekora-senpai!
She had some very good luck betting on horses.
Arima Kimi.
Really famous horse races in Japan.
And you know what happened over Christmas?
And I think a number of senpai decided to place some bets on horses today.
I was a bit confused as to what senpai was doing.
But Pekora senpai, she won big!
She won over a million yen, over $10,000 American!
That's pretty... That's pretty weird.
That's amazing, right?
That's amazing, right
She probably used all of 2024's luck too high.
Probably.
Why did you use the ruffians?
I don't know, I wonder about these things.
I see.
Maybe not.
But you know, Mio-senpai was talking about buying New Year's fortune tickets for us too.
Right!
So we were happy.
We were happy but... I think Mio-senpai could say, Oh, I'll do anything with FUWAMOCO and we'd be happy.
But yeah, you know, but more than fortune tickets, I think, you know, we just wanna
BAU BAU!
It's that time of the week.
It's a new year!
A new week and a new challenge!
Right!
So, this week too, Moco-chan's gonna do her best to challenge and overcome her fear of natto!
Yeah, we've been at this for a while.
Ruffians, you know that natto is a type of breakfast food in Japan that consists of fermented soybeans.
It's really healthy for you, but it's kind of something else.
Mococo-chan, you did really well with the sesame oil last time.
I did!
I've been doing well!
That's why this time, I decided to go very minimal.
Very minimal.
Do things the way that we started them.
Because it's the start of a new year, right?
Start of a new year, you know?
And I think...
Maybe Moco-chan, maybe this is more of like a... You kinda gotta just convince yourself that you can eat them!
It's a part of the heart.
My heart has been wrong and that's why I haven't been able to eat it.
Is that what you're saying?
Well, that could be one thing.
Okay, Moco-chan, you ready?
Okay, I guess.
Do you have my favorite chopsticks?
No.
It's another part you have to get over, Moco-chan.
Can I use chopsticks?
Is that okay?
Yeah.
I'm allowed.
I don't have to use my hands.
No.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Thank you!
The natto.
It looks very... A little bit different.
A bit different.
It doesn't smell that much, does it?
I... I don't know.
I'm sort of... I'm sort of confident today, I think.
You know, it's New Year.
New life.
Mouthful you think.
Okay, Moco-chan.
First, let's say thank you to the FUWAMOZUKONCHIGI who tried to make this okay.
Itadakimasu!
Thank you very much!
I don't smell it today, maybe that means my allergies is worse.
Worse?
Positive.
Allergies are worse!
BAU BAU!
Okay, well, let's try it!
Different kind of energy today, huh?
It's a bit different, huh?
Yeah.
Okay, let's try it.
Is this a different... a different... not flavor, but... No, it's the same as always.
Is it the same as always?
Yeah, you just have to believe.
Okay, I'll have to believe, okay.
Okay, Moco-chan, make sure you take a big...
Big, big, big, big, big one.
Okay.
It's a big one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Can you believe it?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
There's no natto.
Confession.
It was forgotten.
We're out of natto.
BAU BAU!
You didn't do it!
It was the most delicious air natto ever.
We're out of natto.
And we realized 30 seconds before starting.
BAU BAU!
We're starting the year on a good paw, right?
Right!
That was a different kind of attempt today, but you were tricked!
Is that a challenge?
Was it a challenge, Moco-chan?
Pulling the ruffians.
I didn't think you would be pulled by the ruffians.
I'm a bit disappointed.
Well, I'd say first challenge of the year succeeded.
Is that how it sounds usually?
I don't think so, huh?
It's so easy, huh?
Ruffians, you know it's a new year, so let's make sure to do our best and challenge ourselves in new areas too, okay?
And that will be continued.
Next week.
When we actually have natto.
Yeah.
Kyou wa ea natto deshita.
Ea natto deshita.
Oishikatta!
BAU BAU!
I'm continuing on!
The first Doggie of the Day?
Oh, it doesn't make it the doggy of the year.
No.
It's the first Doggie of the Day of the year.
Let's see who the Doggie of the Day of the year is!
The Doggie of the Day of the year is...
It's... Gutierrez!
Gutierrez!
BAU BAU!
I feel like he's looking into my soul.
Oh, well, you know Gutierrez.
He's a good boy.
Good bad manners.
What do you think of that, Moco-chan?
Well... I feel like you can see all of my thoughts in my head, so...
Maybe I'll forgive him.
Okay, yeah.
You know, he's doing his best.
Apparently, you know, this is his I'm-not-a-fan-of-fireworks face.
Yeah.
I get that.
I like fireworks, but you know, sometimes it can be a bit surprising and then I look like... How does he BAU BAU?
I think...
If it's the I'm not a fan of fireworks time, then maybe it's like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
I think that's exactly it.
This is bad.
Good tears is on a journey of self-growth.
You know, he has good intentions and is a good boy, but sometimes makes mistakes too.
Yeah, you know, that's just how things are sometimes.
No such thing as a perfect puppy.
Yeah, but I have a good feeling, you know.
A new year!
A new good year!
BAU BAU!
Cute.
Well, Ruffians, you're still going out for walks, right?
Well, here is the first walk of the day of the year.
De-den!
Wonderful Comiket day!
Beautiful.
Oh, the winter sun.
And you got Icomochi-mama's FUWAMOCO goods!
BAU BAU!
Very, very cute!
We're so glad you had a lot of fun.
Yeah, but now it's time to rest after a surely very busy Comiket.
Right.
Time to rest.
Time to enjoy.
Enjoy your treasures, your spoils.
Put your feet up.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our first question of the day of the year.
De-den!
BAU BAU!
Good question.
Ruffians.
Ruffians!
Maybe it's good to get dis- uh, to be ready to get disappointed.
It's good to be disappointed!
Is that what you wanted to say?
No!
Get ready to be disappointed because, um, at least, you know, my thought is, on the first playthrough of the game, you know, I kind of want to have the best experience, right?
Right?
And sometimes, maybe, Fuwawa might not pick-
The best heroine to go with to have the best experience of the game.
So, I kind of searched up online what the recommended playthrough order is.
And, I will, even if the heroine I'm most interested in, if she's in the last, the last one to play, I still follow the recommendations.
Isn't that the worst ruffians?
That's cheating!
But I feel like the developers, they want me to have the best experience, right?
Same!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, you go with least interested?
But then what if you're like, oh, I really don't like her, and then you're like, this game, mm-mm.
Right?
That would be kind of sad, so.
But I feel like, generally, this method hasn't failed me yet.
You know, even for Chihuahua, I did that, and I was definitely very glad I did because, you know, Mochi!
Mochi!
Hi!
Our favorite!
You know, she was the final rule, and I feel like that was the perfect way to complete the game.
It's important.
Yeah.
A lot of tears.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the question!
Thank you so much, ruffians, for all your Doggie of the Day, your scoops today, some great journalism, your questions, too.
Headpats, too.
Important part, right?
No, headpats for the ruffians.
Oh, headpats for the ruffians.
And for Mococo.
Thank you so much, ruffians!
Please, please continue to support FUWAMOCO Morning in the new year in 2024.
Here you know, FUWAMOCO Morning is going to always be a show that's made all together, so we hope you'll continue to feel that way, too!
BAU BAU!
Oh, well, for our next team, what do we have, Moco-chan?
Wow.
Ruffians, as you might know, our next stream was going to be our Advent.
I think we're going to be having our New Year outfit reveals, but there's been a bit of a change of plans and our outfit reveal won't be able to happen tonight.
But because of that, we made some changes to our schedule.
Instead,
We'll be doing a very comfy and cozy super chat.
Is that okay, Ruffians?
We'll spend some nice time.
We hope that you'll be there with us.
Just nice and cozy, filled with laughs.
We hope that you'll really look forward to our new year outfit reveals in the very
Near future.
Soon, okay?
Soon.
It just means we get to look forward to it more, you know?
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
This is what our schedule looks like.
I would like to let you know that there might be a number of schedule changes kinda out there.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, ruffians, for joining us today for the first FUWAMOCO Morning of 2024!
I hope that you'll continue to wake up early and allow us to help you start the day off on the right paw.
Protect your smile straight from the beginning of the morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special ruffians!
Hi!
What were you gonna say?
Extra special ruffians.
He stopped.
Hi.
Extra special ruffians.
Oh, I didn't think you finished the sentence.
I did.
Extra special ruffians!
Hibana time!
BAU BAU!
Novel!
Ever Unknown!
BAU BAU!
Gears of War!
Sky Clover!
BAU BAU!
Hunter!
Yuibou.
BAU BAU!
Mr. Fujisawa.
Ahogador.
BAU BAU!
Dragon Ruffian.
Aqui.
BAU BAU!
Balloon Jacking.
Sammy.
BAU BAU!
Jess.
The Slayer.
BAU BAU!
Mizukusai.
Tenshi.
BAU BAU!
Aku.
Meow.
BAU BAU!
Dragon Warrior.
Grill Jones.
BAU BAU!
Mahamuto.
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
And a very Happy New Year!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!